any personal and disappointment I have
this result is as nothing compared to
the sense of sorrow I have at the result
that Labour has achieved across United
Kingdom tonight in Scotland but also in
England and in Wales and the sense of
concern I have about the future we will
now face five years where questions will
arise about the future of our union
about whether or not we can stay as a
member of the European Union and fight
for jobs and investment whether we can
make sure we secure our national health
service at a time of public spending
cuts and those are real concerns to me
and to many people across the United
Kingdom even on this very difficult
night I would just like to say I've been
proud to be a Labour and cooperative
Member of Parliament and we have always
been a party which has been
internationalist because we believe
we've sold problems by working with
other countries to solve them we've
always been a party which believed in
the Union because the pooling and
sharing of risk which comes from our
union underpins justice and fairness
we've always been the party who founded
the National Health Service and we'll do
everything we can to secure the future
the National Health Service even on this
difficult night I'm sure the Labour
Party will emerge in the coming weeks
and months more United and more
determined and in the next few years I
think more than ever we will need in
Parliament and across the country a
Labour Party absolutely determined to
stand up for working people in this
constituency and in our country
I am confident labour will be back thank
you very much